addiction is a an automatic process we
get caught in the loop and we struggle
to see beyond it in order to give
yourself hope you need to start looking
beyond what you're currently
experiencing so if you were no longer
trapped by addiction what would be going
on in your life think about your
environment your behavior the people
around you how you'd be feeling what
values would become important to you
your beliefs explore it welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm I'm your host Heim
Maus and on this week's episode I was
joined by Dan Martin you've been
qualified as a therapist for coming up
to going towards 2 years and you found
yourself helping people in the fitness
industry mhm and then you then have uh
your business called Freedom solution
where you help high functioning
professionals break free from addiction
sadan is now an addiction therapist he
works with what he likes to call
high functioning addicts so on the
outside they have all of the perceived
success status but on the inside there's
turmoil and Dan is talking from
experience he spent 8 years in the
recruitment industry and at his worst
when his habits and his addiction was at
the worst he was out five times a week
having 5 G of cocaine at a time drinking
several nights of the week and he found
himself in this cycle but but he's been
on this amazing growth Journey since
then where he's turned what he's gone
through into his superpower to help
other people he's now a qualified
hypnotherapist and NLP practitioner and
actively helps a lot of people actually
in the recruitment industry who may be
suffering with addiction and we spoke
about how to spot addiction when does a
bad habit become an addiction I think
it's an important discussion
what often holds people back from taking
that first step to maybe getting help
that's a great question and let's get
into this week's episode Dan welcome to
the podcast thank you great to be here
appreciate you making the trip uh have
really enjoyed our conversations up
until this point in preparation for this
I've really enjoyed learning about your
story the people that you now help the
the mission that you're now on and I
think I'm always keen and open mind to
have important
conversations that can hopefully be
helpful for people that listen to this
podcast which is a lot of recruiters a
lot of high
Achievers which is why I think the
conversation that we'll have today could
be really helpful maybe even
transformational for some people so I'm
going to just give a bit of background
and then I'd love to just start with
just going through some of the important
moments of your story that I've learned
since getting to know you so let me know
if I get any of this wrong but I think I
wrote down um when we prepared for this
you worked in the recruitment industry
for seven to eight
years you worked as a recruiter for a
number of years but then you also worked
in the in the recruitment industry in
the sense that you sold a financial
solution to recruitment companies so you
was in the recruitment ecosystem for a
good amount of time um and that's a
quite important part of like your
journey um so that's what you're doing
work-wise and then now you've been on
this personal journey I guess I'd say
where you've been qualified as a
therapist for coming up to going towards
two years and you found yourself helping
people in the fitness industry mhm from
the high performance mindset standpoint
Y and then you then have uh your
business called Freedom solution yep is
that right yeah cool um where you help
high functioning professionals break
free from addiction right know smashed
it so there's a lot to unpack here so
like let's and I know that you've also
worked with a number of recruiters yeah
right um in that which is why I was I
was really interested to to have you on
I've seen your post I think you're
diding a really good job of building
your brand I've got some of the LinkedIn
post today that you've shared which I
want to you know break down with you but
why don't why don't we just start with
um understanding a bit more about your
story cuz I feel like my perception of
uh you know the types of people that do
what you do uh we can go into the the
core drivers why you do what you do but
often times I found that people have
been on their own Journey with whatever
that may be and then they've you know
had that growth and they almost feel
like if they weren't to help people
experience the same they're almost doing
like a disservice uh to themselves right
so where where does this story start for
you like when when I meet you and I'm
maybe speaking to you about you know
working with you as a therapist I might
fall into this Camp of uh a high
functioning professional that might
labor myself as an addict or I'm not
sure if uh you know I'd say I'm an
addict but I always end up in these
certain
situations and you start talking to me
about look I've I've experienced similar
things to you like where where do you of
where do you often start the story in
terms of where Dan's Journey started
with all this are we talking about with
therapy or with addiction I'd probably
say with addiction yeah so like where do
you often tell people like this was like
where it started for me it started
really really young to be honest with
you I was actually reflecting on this
last night ahead of this just journaling
a little bit to explore in a bit more
detail and it really started at age 15
I'd say that was the first time I found
some form of substance that had a bit of
a hold over me and um I won't go too far
into school details but ultimately I
didn't really feel like a fit in right I
felt like a bit of a misfit didn't feel
like I had a real close friendship group
I'd looked to other groups and think oh
why can't I have that and weed cannabis
was something that gave me an
opportunity to have that because there
was a group of people you know like the
gothic people you don't really see that
many of these guys these days but
there's a a goth Gothic uh I think it
actually more called like an emo group
at the time and I fell in with them and
um cannabis was a big part of the
culture within that group so that's
where my journey with addiction started
and immediately can form a link between
smoking weed and getting a form of
connection from it and at the time told
myself oh it's just fun it's just
feeling High and getting stoned and
whatever but looking back on it now I
can see that really I was looking for a
sense of connection and and belonging
within that group you know so that's
where the story starts and then it
escalated quite a lot and went in es and
flows over the years you know it wasn't
cannabis at 15 and then I'm straight on
to to cocaine which is ultimately where
I met um the hardest point of my life
but started at 15 and um and went from
there how do you want me to continue
from here where do you want me to take
the story from here where where did this
where like if you're happy to show cuz
it it might be something that you found
in people that you've worked with but
where where did this sort of longing of
connection come from that's a big
question yeah we're going there yeah so
the longing for connection ultimately
comes from the fact I'm adopted right so
um I was adop adopted at a very young
age at 3 months old adopted by my
parents and I'm not going to s sit here
and say that I had a tough upbringing
because I didn't I wouldn't be sat here
opposite you having incredible
conversations with people like you had I
not had the upbringing that I did have
I'm very grateful for the upbringing
that I did have but what we are doing
when we're children is forming
beliefs and our sense of the world
through beliefs beliefs essentially
become our operating system and analogy
that I really like to use when we talk
about beliefs is um hardware and
software right the conscious mind is
like the hardware and you pick up your
iPhone you're looking at Hardware you're
not seeing all of the ones and zeros
behind the screen you're seeing Hardware
that's your conscious mind that's I'm
going to pick up this can I'm going to
take a drink after this podcast I'm
going to walk out that door I might go
and grab a coffee sit down do some work
it's me actively and proactively
thinking about what I'm going to do
that's your that's your conscious mind
MH and then the software is your
subconscious mind so that's where your
beliefs live and really in the same way
that the software within a phone becomes
the operating system and the
functionality of the device your beliefs
in your unconscious mind create the
operating system through which you view
reality so when I was adopted at a very
young age a belief was formed of well
I'm just not good enough for birth
parents despite all the evidence to
suggest that I had a great life that was
a belief that was formed so we carry
those beliefs with us through childhood
into adulthood and when I draw this back
to wanting to fit in with a group
smoking weed
if I feel like oh I just not wasn't good
enough or I wasn't deserving of Love by
getting in with that group and smoking
weed guess what that does makes me feel
like I am you are yeah does that make
sense how I but that does that does make
sense no I appreciate you sharing
that cuz I I I
think I always when I have these types
of conversations it makes me feel
like
how grateful I am for for like my
parents in the sense that my definitely
relationship with my parents has never
been always like perfect but what I mean
by that is I think whenever I speak to
people uh who haven't had the typical
you know
setup where your mom and dad stayed
together for X number of years or
whatever I find myself feeling grateful
for that cuz I can I can't fully
understand you know how that could make
you feel but I think often times people
that come from a home where their mom
and dad have stayed together for you
know a period of time they haven't got
divorced or these other things uh you
can probably take that for granted yeah
but in like if you if you don't mind
sharing I'm just I'm just curious like
when as you're like in your formative
Years cuz you you always see I feel like
in like films play out and stuff or like
drama series that I watch where if
someone one is adopted there'll come a
point where you're really curious about
who your parents are did you go for I
don't know I feel like that's you always
see that depicted I don't know if that's
accurate but I feel like in like you
know watching stuff I don't know that's
like a quite common storyline where
someone grows older they then start
thinking about who are my actual parents
I've had these amazing adopted parents
I'm so thankful for but
who who are who are my parents did you
go through that yeah I've been through
that several times over the years and
last year was when it kind of peaked I
think it was laying on the sofa with my
girlfriend and out of nowhere this
Insight came to me it's like you need to
go and meet your birth parents really
yeah and I don't know where it came from
but it just came to me and it kind of
produced a wave of emotion and I
reflected on it and then I actually
raised it with my therapist in my next
session with him I said I think I got
this his name's Hugh my therapist Hugh I
got this burning desire to go and see my
birth parents and you went well what are
you hoping to find what if they don't
share that desire I thought [__] you're
right like I could be building this up
to a big Monumental point where I think
oh we're going to meet it's going to be
lovely we're going to connect and feel
love and all these emotions but there's
no guarantee of that and in reality it
could have caused more discomfort than
not knowing so I accepted that right now
just isn't the perfect time to do that
because I mean where do we even start
with that like I've got no idea where to
start and I don't if I look Within
Myself deeply is there something
inherently missing that would be filled
by meeting them no not right now I've
got everything that I need right now
that doesn't mean to say that at some
point in the future I will pursue it but
it's not as straightforward as running
the Google search going who are my birth
parents right like it's complex I can
imagine I can again obviously I can't
relate but I can just imagine it would
just be just a real sense of curiosity
like who are these people how much are
they like me how I don't know yeah it's
exactly that it's curiosity I know that
this is something that's um big on your
hierarchy of values right curiosity is
it's a it's a driving force in my life
as well hence why I became a therapist I
want to learn more about humans and
understand how I can help them and it's
there there is a question in my mind who
are they what are they doing what are
they like what are their values do they
align with
mine so would you agree then in your own
Journey because you often grow up
hearing weed is the gateway drug other
drugs would you would you agree with
that would that would did that play
quite an important part in then
exploring other drugs in your life yeah
for me it certainly was a gateway drug
but I do not believe that we live in an
either or Universe in so far as
everything has to be either this or that
yeah for some people people which I know
personally they can smoke weed and have
no interest in doing anything beyond
that and they can go to work hold down a
job build a life build a family while
still smoking
wheat it's not going to be the same for
everyone and it certainly wasn't the
same for me for me it absolutely was a
gateway drug
but there's a fine line between
enjoyment and escapism and when I was
using weed unconsciously it was escapism
for me at the time because of all of the
stuff that I was packaging away from
childhood and weed became what was
essentially a form of medicine for me so
get some form of um emotional relief
from smoking weed naturally I wanted
more of that so moved on to other things
and I can move on to not too long after
that
actually still at age 15 at this point
in time I don't know if you remember
this but there was a drug which came out
MCAT MCAT you remember that big yeah it
was huge so many people on that yeah I
was I was and I never did it to be fair
but I definitely remember like just
hearing people doing it at parties and
that was like a very popular drug yeah
cuz I'm I'm 30 right I feel like we're
similar ages I was born in 1993 yeah so
I feel like that that definitely had
like its moment was like plant
fertilizer or something it was yeah yeah
and it it was crazy strong like crazy
crazy strong I remember police coming
into school one day and I don't know if
this story was true I was just trying to
scare M her but I remember them saying
that there was somebody who took Mone
and they ripped a car door off CU they
were so
high ripped a car door off yeah that was
the story they gave and I was 16 years
old my 16th birthday was spent going
backwards and forwards to a row of shops
picking up more and more of this MCAT
stuff because it was it was so cheap and
it was so
pure it was still legal yeah it's mad
that when
those like people discover these like
legal hires yeah you I always think like
who was the first person to like get
that in the system do you know what I
mean there was like oh my God this is
unreal yeah yeah produce more of this I
think there are Labs all around the
world which are trying to find loopholes
to manufacture new drugs which are
essentially doing the same thing as the
one which has now been made legal but
they can just brand it as something
different and then it can legally be
sold in shops you know like
great example of that remember that was
FL I feel like that's really that was
really big up north yeah yeah a lot of
homeless people that's right we' be
using that right yeah that's right yeah
so that so quite so quite quickly then
you were also getting exposed to other
drugs at and bar smoking weird yeah I
was and it was it was systemic in
the the culture of the Friendship group
that I was in at that point in time it's
just what we did is just a bunch of
people who were really like paper bags
FL through the wind none of us had any
ambition we didn't have any desire to
create anything or do anything with our
lives there was a very wide um spectrum
of of Ages you know we were there at the
bottom end at 15 16 years old but then
there were people there who were in
their early 20s and we were all in a
very similar mindset we just didn't know
what we wanted to do with our lives so
it was so much easier just to smoke weed
and take drugs because hey it's fun you
don't have to worry about anything when
you do I haven't got much else to worry
about right yeah that's right yes I
always the thing is is like when you're
that when you're that young and I do
view that as like really young I know
when you're at those ages you think
you're a lot older than you are yeah
but it's interesting
because how what is the the chances or
likelihood of Dan like Breaking Free
from that friendship group if he feels
like it's not serving him I I don't see
that I don't feel like that's very high
I feel like
when you're younger you just want to fit
in yes so to even think about I'm not
going to go to this party tonight cuz
last time I did MCAT it was a bit weird
but like there I I feel like that's so
hard which is
why so much can happen if you get in
with the quite and quite bad crowd when
you're younger
right it's and I don't know if yeah
that' be so hard to break free from it
yeah when you're younger yeah it would
have been but importantly at the time I
had no desire to because like I talk
about you know not feeling enough and
challenging emotions and all of the pain
I was experiencing now having
got over a 100 hours of therapy and
coaching under my belt personally and
trained as a therapist I understand this
stuff now it's hard to even have the
level of selfness to be aware of this
stuff if you don't know what you're
looking for right and I had no idea what
I was looking for there was just
discomfort there but I didn't want to go
near it I was like consciously choosing
to ignore that and instead just
intoxicate myself so at the time I
wasn't ready and um having a
conversation with someone on LinkedIn
about this yesterday um when it when it
comes to addiction really in order to do
something about it you have to arrive at
a place of acceptance and willingness to
confront all of your [__] that
you're ignoring and do something about
it and everybody traveling at different
speeds and not everybody will be ready
at the same time
that's why you hear about interventions
that take place and then they just get
thrown thrown back around in in their
face because the person's not ready to
receive that kind of news and at this
point in my life I certainly wasn't
ready I I had a lot more
self-destruction to do before I arrived
at the place of rock Boton going [__] I
need to do yeah so where where did we
where did we go from here then so 16
17 yeah like obviously weed MCAT when
did and was the in in looking back was
just the perception here like I have a
group of friends we do drugs sometimes
it's recreational it's it's good fun
that that was like the language I'm
assuming or like the perception of what
you was doing yes rather than actually
yeah maybe I I feel like when I do do
this stuff I'm always thinking about the
next time we can do it and you know I'm
assuming you didn't think of this word
addict or addiction back then no it
wasn't something that was in my
conscious awareness but I wasn't aware
that I was crossing the line between
addiction and independency cuz there is
addiction and independency there is a
difference between addiction and
independency in so far as addiction is
more of a towards movement we'll go out
of our way to try and find something
right dependence is I can't function
unless I have this thing and cannabis
did become like that for me it become so
frequent using it every day sometimes
smoking it before school when I was at
that age and I genuinely didn't feel
like I could function without it
obviously I could but at the time
psychologically
I need this stuff in order to function
so kind of cross the line between
addiction and move towards dependence at
that point in time yeah I always find it
fascinating people that can like
function dayto day yeah by starting
their day just smoking a fat one a lot
of them never understood that yeah I
just cuz yeah it's mad a dependency in
addiction that's an interesting
distinction to be fair so he was
crossing those lines and then how does
this how did this start to evolve then
you know when did we start you know um
exploring with different drugs like when
yeah when did where did where did we go
from here with our journey with using
narcotics there was a a brief moment of
rest bite around age 17 where I wasn't
using a great deal of anything every now
and again I'd smoke some weed I was
still drinking but the level up towards
harder drugs happened when I got into
the corporate world world so mhm age 18
I was actually working as a mechanic at
that point in time still didn't really
know what to do just knew that I loved
cars I thought I going work in a
workshop hated it couldn't stand being
dirty and cold and making teens sweeping
up [__] all day long so didn't stay
there very long um I
was around 18 at my Nan's funeral at the
time and my cousin who was a year
younger than me just having a general
chat with him he said I've just started
working in sales and he he was
earning I can't remember the exact
figure but he was earning as near as
making a difference double what I was
earning working as a mechanic and I
thought egoic well if he can do it then
I can do it so that's where my journey
into the corporate world and sales
started and um I landed a job at a
leaflet Distribution Company which is
very old school sales here's a list of
numbers go out and find some business
kind of thing and I was tasked to go
around and um
pitch leaflet distribution services to
businesses in London and um it was tough
didn't have a clue how to write an email
didn't have a clue to speak on the phone
no idea what I was doing but taught me
hell of a lot about getting rejected and
told to get the [__] out of the shop
right it which is really powerful but
that was my first instruction in sales
and then from there I left that job and
went into Recruitment and that's where
um I had done cocaine previously but not
very much it wasn't something that kind
of had its grip over me at that point in
time but in that environment that's
where everything started to ramp up and
um
cocaine and steroids actually became a
part of my life at that point in time so
we can go wherever you want to go from
there well yeah let's just talk about
this cuz that that's also why I wanted
to have this conversation cuz I think a
lot of people listening have been around
those uh people that use those drugs in
the in the recruitment industry so cuz
you you were worked you worked for um
you worked as a recruiter for a couple
of years and I'm assuming like how how
successful were you like were you
earning the most money that you had had
up until that point like do you know
what I mean financially was you doing
well okay I was doing okay it was it was
um I don't know very low basic as much
recruitment entry level recruitment jobs
are for maybe like 15 16k a year
something like that and then with
commission maybe up to 24 25k something
around that sort of Mark so at the time
for someone who had just come from um an
apprenticeship as a mechanic which was
earning you know very very low wage then
going to work in that other business
selling leaflet distribution services
where I didn't earn any Commission on
about 15 16 Grand a year to me it was a
lot of money at the time MH it was a lot
of money so it was easy to spend
it and like what and what was you living
a home yeah living at home yeah with my
um with my dad at the time okay and like
how did this how did this first show up
then like how did cocaine first show up
with you in in the recruitment context
then was it Friday night you know week
one of the boys thought let's get a bag
in like how did it how did it initially
show up often times yeah that it's
exactly like that it started off as
being you know actually usually a
Thursday night interesting th night
really yeah Thursday Thursdays didn't
I've worked from home Fridays either as
well Friday yeah yeah every Friday
sometimes staying up until 5 6:00 in the
morning watching the sun come up through
the blinds hearing the birds jumping at
window knowing that you got to pull
yourself together and get to work within
the next couple of hours it was it was
tough but yeah it started off as being
just a a Thursday and Friday night and
um escalated from
there a few years later really it it was
only I say only two times per week
whilst over that period um again
emotionally at the time wasn't aware
that there was anything wrong with what
I was doing I was kind of caught up in
the process of just want to earn money
MH just want to have a good time I've
earned this if I've had a hard week at
work I deserve to be able to go out and
let my hair down at the weekend there's
no harm in doing this no
responsibilities really I'm living with
my dad M there's no problem here so
stayed that way for a few years mhm um
but this is at the same sort of time
that I was starting to dabble in
steroids as well where did that come
from insecurity yeah it often does when
you're younger than that yeah yeah
absolutely insecurity and impatience had
only recently started training at the
gym enjoyed it
but playing into the addictive
Tendencies of my mind if there's
something that I enjoy Joy I want more
of it I want to dial it up as much as
possible and this is I'm not a finished
article right like I sit here now and I
still have to control myself at times
this is just something that's hardwired
into my
DNA started going to the gym the same
guy who I do coke with at that um
recruitment agency says oh have you
thought about anavar and anavar is like
a tablet steroid right so um fairly
subtle in terms of its effects tried
that oh that's good look how much much
what I've built in such a short amount
of time but what what was the why was it
what was the like M if you thought about
this cuz you can get bigger like even
quicker was it as simple as that it
wasn't even that it at the time I didn't
really know that it was a steroid like
it wasn't explicitly explained that we
hear steroid it's kind of a loaded word
right it's kind you I feel I don't know
about you but as soon as I hear the word
steroid you think about injections going
in bums yes is what you I is like what
where my mind goes yeah yeah well that's
what it went to next so I only took an
of our for a very short amount of time
and naturally wanted more so
testosterone came along and it was
actually positioned to me as being even
safer than anavar oh well if that's the
case then crack on load me up
yeah but was and and the motivation
behind that was combined with like you
like you said being subconscious wanted
some of the other things you said around
like you wanted to dial up your getting
into your training MH but would was it
as simple as I want to look good I want
to I want to get big as simple as that
it was purely aesthetically driven there
was no I'm going to compete at this
competition in a couple of years time it
was I just want to get as big as
possible so people will validate
me I definitely know people it's
interesting it came up in our friend
WhatsApp group recently
like I feel like anyone listen to this
they'll likely as a guy know at least at
least one person that started using
steroids [__] early MH cuz that then
as well even you know early late teens
early
20s again you're still so like want you
care about other people's opinions so
much
so you
absolutely in those years do I don't
know how you found it but you you would
have found I'm assuming some sort of
validation from it yeah cuz I know
the guy that I'm thinking of in iot
Talent grew up
with his arms were [__] huge and like
I'd always be thinking how the F how
yeah and I just know back then that
would have probably made him really feel
good that people looked at him that way
mhm but then it just came up on a
friendship group recently night one of
our friends went to the gym uh went to
David Lloyd in the local area that we
grew up and was in the sa ended up
talking about this guy saying like he's
had two heart attacks and like yeah he
would have been he's younger would have
been younger than me and it is just mad
cuz again when you are those um in those
formative years again when you start
training you want to fit in you can
easily make decisions like the decisions
that you made yeah and they have
long-term repercussions to the point
where because I abused them steroids
that is for such a long time on and off
for about 5 years with no safety
precautions I'm now at a point where my
natur testosterone is struggling to get
within normal range and I'm 28 years old
that's not right it shouldn't be like
that and energetically I feel okay but
it shouldn't be as low as it is now and
something that we spoke about when we
were on our our prep call is
the condition that I developed
gynecomastia where um without going into
too many details I had to have surgery
on my chest because of a hormone
imbalance and that cost me the best part
of £3,000 which I didn't have spare at
that point in time all because I wanted
immediate gratification or very very
shortterm gratification from taking
steroids but when we're young
particularly operating from um highly
driven ambitious and insecure mindset
like I was don't don't care about the
long-term cussions we just want to get
big quick and get ticks in the boxes
from a validation perspective yeah no
totally so that mixed with
then the use of cocaine increasing
that's that's some mix
that yeah
how how like again in hindsight and
we're going to go into your journey
in you know uh I don't know if the right
time is like better control or like
making different decisions holding
yourself accountable so the reason why I
bring that up is because sort of
what I'd love to just get your take on
is like how influential were the people
you was around in these sorts of
decisions mhm but I don't want that to
be in a way where you're like pointing
the finger cuz I don't think that's
helpful right it's like oh I made this
decision CU of so and so you don't
really give yourself any power in in
having that perception but like you like
the your tribe is so important
M so how how much of this with this in
continued increase usage in these in
these years was like the environment you
was in how much of an impact did that
have 2018 is when I left um being on the
tools so to speak as a recruiter and
went to the other side of the def fense
and joined um what recruiters will
recognize as an umbrella company yeah
and um their environment contributed
massively that's where everything
started to really ramp up in terms of
usage m so um most most most recruiters
whether they're contract or permanent
will know that the relationship that has
developed between umbrella companies and
recruitment consultancies is largely
built upon the foundation of um dropping
gifts off smoing taking out for meals
boozing all that kind of stuff for
someone like myself who was already
struggling with addictive behaviors that
is a recipe for disaster my employer
goes there's a company credit card we
need you to go out and build
relationships with the rec is do it by
any means
necessary so that that became my tribe
and the tribe which I had outside of my
professional life were also people who
were into the party scene so it was
drink and drugs and destructive
behaviors there so I would be going out
you know two times per week taking out
recruiters which would be largely fueled
by drink and often drugs as well and
then Thursday Friday Saturday I'd be out
with friends partying so it was from
every angle contributing towards these
destructive behaviors that I was stuck
in so went more from like two two times
a week
to four five four fives sometimes six
yeah it was a lot so what a lot where
when was this at its worst then cuz I
feel like this is what you're talking
about where it dialed up like when was
your relationship with cocaine at its
worst would you say in terms of the
amount that you used it or like at the
yeah at the first it would have been
2018 really yeah7 back end of 2017 going
into 2018 that's when it was what did
that actually look like what did it look
like in terms of the work life as I said
it was two three times per week out in
London going to regular cocktail bars
and clubs afterwards until the early
hours of the morning stay on random
hotel somewhere greatfully paid for by
the company I was working for at the
time and then in my personal life I'd be
going out to Raves and sometimes just at
home stood around a kitchen table until
4 5:00 in the morning so how many grams
are we doing a week at this point grams
a week that's an interesting
question grams a week you know what I
mean like what is like a ground like
yeah you know how how much are we doing
average I'd say average night out would
be I try and get the the stronger stuff
which generally comes in half grams
right so generally two or three pure
typically yeah that's right so a gram
and a half of that a night probably so
we must that doing that four five times
a week you know five five six GRS a week
I guess something like that of the pure
stuff something around that sort of
Mark what is it that you enjoyed most
about it cuz I never I never really
rated it like I've done it a number of
times and
always just
felt I don't know know I've just never
if I think of the the times I've done it
it's normally been on nights out with
mate stuff like that I don't know I've
never really rate I've never really like
proper rated it like what is it that it
it get like in terms of how did it
really how did you really enjoy it or
what is it that you really enjoyed about
it I thought about this a lot and there
are three things okay
firstly confidence wasn't a very
confident guy and I was working in a job
where it was my responsibility to form
relationships with people which would
then reumer me financially so if I took
cocaine I'd feel a lot more confident
I'd be able to have better conversations
with people which would then lead me to
more professional success so in my mind
I was like well this is just a win-win
this is this is obviously a good thing
so firstly confidence but then it gets a
little bit darker because it gave me
freedom because at that point in time
2018 I was experiencing discomfort I
knew that I was feeling anxious I didn't
want to go near it but I was aware that
there was something going on inside my
body and this was an accumulation of the
adoption realization and I also lost my
adopted mom when I was 18 years old and
I just chose not to protest any of that
consciously disregarded all of that
grief didn't want to go near it so there
was that that I was avoiding and it gave
me freedom from that as well and it
would also give me what I would Now
define as like Charisma it made me feel
like I had something you remember
earlier on in the conversation we was
talking about me never really feeling
like I fit in it gave me that connection
and that sense of fitting in it made me
feel charismatic so confidence freedom
and Charisma SL connection is what I'd
get from
cocaine
yeah to be fair I'm not confidence
totally
get Charisma also I I do get that cuz
you're sort of like yeah it sort of amps
things up a bit doesn't it it's like
yeah yeah I get the I get the freedom
piece in terms of I feel like that's
where we're talking talking about like
escapism right that's right yeah I said
earlier there's a very fine line between
enjoyment and
escapism
so what ended up being cuz you said you
said right it's difficult to help
someone that doesn't want to be helped
mhm
so was there like a a specific moment
that was like H rock bottom or what was
like the lead Domino of maybe you
starting to have these thoughts of like
why why do I end up always making these
decisions or why do I always end up in
these scenarios like was yeah what
started to Bubble away and
why it was an existential crisis that
took place and the trigger event was
completely outside of my control so it
was actually the pandemic that caused me
to have that look in the mirror and
understand that I needed to make a
change and it wasn't an overnight
process it was something that happened
gradually
over about a year to be honest so we
went into the first lockdown when March
2020 right around that sort of time yeah
I'm living in Hitchin hartfordshire at
the time and the lifestyle that I'm
living in so far going out
partying up until that point is no
longer possible I'm not able to do that
anymore so I'm stuck with my thoughts
and I have no choice but to look in the
mirror and be with myself now I'm still
smoking a lot of weed at this point in
time I didn't do a hell of a lot of hard
drugs over that lockdown period but I
did smoke a lot of weed and that's
because I still just wasn't quite ready
to process all of the all of the
discomfort that was going on so that was
the trigger event and um over that
summer I didn't really really face up to
a hell of a lot I was just smoking weed
but then towards the end of
2020 the lease was up on that flat that
I was living in so I went back home to
move in with my dad for a little while
and something happened when I moved back
home there after having a break from the
house in which I grew up in and spent so
much time you know taking MCAT and
smoking weed and all this kind of stuff
when I went back there something didn't
feel right something felt disconnected
for me and I I woke up a little bit and
for whatever reason I just felt a
burning desire to just push the reset
button so I knew that I had to get away
and actually turn my attention inwards
and understand what was going on inside
of myself so having never been to Wales
before I moved to Wales and the reason
for that is because I was also doing a
lot of mountain biking at the time and I
thought how can I leverage the one thing
that I am able to do all of the other
stuff that I used to love doing like
going out and parying that's not
possible but the one thing I can still
do is ride my bike how can I make that
as enjoyable as possible moved to Wales
so I found a random room on spare room
photos were awful and I don't know what
I was thinking moving there it very
suspicious to suspect but I moved to
this Random House in the middle of Wales
and it was moving there that I started
to truly wake up and understand who Dan
was and what Dan was running away from
so um there was one book that
interestingly my best mate told me to
buy to sell to another friend of ours
who was really struggling with
depression at the time and I forgot to
send that book to him and I took that
book with me and I thought well it makes
sense for me to just kind of start
reading this book right and it's called
the drummer and the great Mountain for
anybody listening who suspects they've
got ADHD by this book what's it called
the drummer and the great Mountain it's
an adult guide book for ADHD okay super
big words which is great for someone
like me with a short attention span and
there are little tasks all the way
through and it really helps you
understand um who you are where you're
going what you're doing what you want to
get out of life so I started reading
that book as a result of reading that
book it brought up a hell of a lot of
emotion for me so gradually over that
period of time 2019 now uh no sorry 21
2021 yeah
2021 um I'm starting to feel depressed
starting to feel depressed starting to
feel depressed yeah I'm I'm processing
like it's it it's a conscious act that
I'm going through at this point in time
for for once in my life I'm welcoming
emotion in rather than pushing it away
with drugs again still smoking weed at
this point but I'm actively trying to
access my emotions at this point in time
so that was the the period at which I
hit close to Rock Bottom not quite there
yet um but that friend of mine who sent
me that book he was studying to be a
therapist at the time and he asked if I
would be willing to practice with him
because as part of your therapeutic
training you need to practice and get
some reps in to understand how to do the
different techniques and methodologies
mhm so that's my introduction into
therapy at that point in time doing it
with my best friend and naturally
there's a limitation to how deep you can
go with a friend because you've got kind
of a previous relationship there and you
don't want to share certain things so uh
kind of start to pull trauma and stuff
out I hadn't gone near before but
doesn't come all the way out right so
that takes us up to
um that would take us to August 2020 and
that's another key milestone in the
story and this is something which I
spoke about on uh my LinkedIn a few days
ago whilst living in
Wales I thought I'm out here in the
middle of nowhere and I've always wanted
to try growing weed so you always wanted
to try growing weed yeah I always wanted
to try growing weed so um mentioned to
the guy who I was staying
with is this okay you have any problems
you well if I don't know about it then
yeah sure no problem that's absolutely
fine so there was a guy who did um some
housing renovation work with this
property that I was living in and I
mentioned to him got quite friendly with
him thinking about buying a cannabis
seed and just growing a plant funny you
should say that come have a look at this
and this big Farmhouse that I'm living
in takes me out to an ous out on the
property and there's a gr there there's
already four
plants this guy's
growing great okay would you want to go
halves then so we go halves and
naturally this same theme which you'll
be picking up on now when I find
something that I like I want to do it
more and more and more so there's four
plants in there at the time we Harvest
it great they came out okay well let's
do six next time okay we did six and
then there was a second barn house and I
thought well I'm going to buy a tent I'm
going to put it in that one and I'm
going to start growing some seedlings
over there whilst these ones are coming
to the end of their Harvest so that by
the time these ones are are done these
ones can be moved into there and we can
have this bit of a cycle going on and
it's important for me to mention that I
had never had any intents of Supply this
was all just like cultivation I just
enjoyed the gardening aspect of doing
this stuff right but um it all it all
came to an end when the landin's
daughter came to visit she knew the
property very well having lived there
for um 25 years while she was growing up
she heard the sound of the extractor fan
out in one of their ouses called the
police and um of of the morning of my
rest I knew that there was something
wrong intuitively there was something
telling me in my body that something was
going to happen and changes around the
corner and um police knocked at the door
it was a very very traumatic day
ultimately um got arrested and had to
leave Wales very very abruptly so that
was the end of my time in Wales it
started off very very strong I started
to understand my emotions generally turn
my attention
inwards that's where I landed on the
realization that I wanted to train as a
therapist I started training as a
therapist while was D in Wales but then
I had this crippling imposter syndrome
whereby I was like I want to work with
people with addiction but I'm also
growing weed plants it was kind of dual
life that was going on I didn't hadn't
really 100% let go of that past identity
that I had whereby I wanted to still be
involved in drugs and all that kind of
stuff that was kind of going in two
different directions you know so short
term getting arrested was awful it was
um very very difficult and traumatic but
long ter was the best thing that ever
happened because it was the existential
kick up the ass that I needed to say
look mate you've got so many good things
going for you here sort your [__] out
sort your stuff out you
know this podcast is proudly partnered
with vin Cherry the all-in-one
recruitment agency software that over
20,000 recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning oneup
sales sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your team team we love partnering with
both of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10% off the usage price
forever use the link in the show notes
to get your hands on that let's get back
to the episode
what it it is crazy how like just what
one decision can lead to I just I'm
always fascinated by that H cuz you told
you shared two experiences
there one your best
friend sharing a book for another friend
which you ended up reading mhm and then
another of someone that you met although
you still had an idea who said hey come
have a look at this
MH just yeah you always I feel like yeah
one it can be just one decision away
right
from yeah like really good things bad
things poor
decisions so yeah I'm not surprised that
that made you really think about what
the [__] am I doing yeah it did it was a
wake up call that I needed yeah and as
one door closes another one opens do you
think everyone do you think people need
do you think most people need a wake up
call specifically within the area of
addiction or just in general I guess
yeah we could call it that that's that's
that's the world that you're in and the
people that you help like have you found
that often times people have had a
moment which they would describe as I
needed the that it was a kick up the
ass I think some people will find their
own way some people will um have a
moment of realization themselves
but others do need it I certainly did
need it I don't know how long I would
have gone on trying to grow weed and
what would have happened from there that
was even at the time something that I
knew I needed so again we don't live in
an i or universe but there are a lot of
people who are struggling with addictive
behaviors which do need that existential
slap around the face to say time to make
a
change so what did the so that year then
2021 clearly a pivotal year for you yes
really started to face like you said the
the emotions that often you've pushed
away yes started
to spend some quality time with your
best friend specifically
around therapy sessions with him because
that's what he needs to do MH I mean I
also really what I also respect about
like what you did there although you
ended up in a situation which ended up
being your kick up kick up the ass but
you did a lot of people wouldn't have
gone like you also really changed your
environment mhm do you know what I mean
you went to Wales it was just you m I'm
sure like that was also probably quite
important because you're in you're
completely out of like when you go to
Wales and and it's you no one no one has
a preconception of like who you are and
mhm what you were yes that's right
that's what I really like about when you
move somewhere like when I mov to London
you know five and a bit years ago like
when you meet anyone they're meeting you
today mhm and you talk about where
you're going M whereas when you stay in
places like where you was you know with
your dad and stuff you will walk around
and people look at you and go oh yeah
that was D he was he was really big
wouldn't he do remember how big he was
when he went to the gym yeah so like I I
do really like that you I really respect
that you did that on your own as well
cuz not a lot I think that takes a lot
of Courage yeah thank you personally um
so what what did you then really start
leading into then you obviously left
whales what did you really start leaning
into that you
feel contined to help you go on this
journey or facing your emotions and like
you
said started to actually become the
person that you needed to be if you did
want to become a therapist that helped
people with addiction like what else did
you start to do well there was another
event something which we've spoken about
again which happened around that same
sort of time as being arrested and that
was a return to work meeting I had with
my boss at the time right that's a
really pivotal point of my journey
because coming back from Lockdown and
going back into the work environment two
major things happened first of all I was
working as a business development
director and after the lockdown the
contract Market saw um a big dip right
as a result of the um pressures that
were put into the economy and as a
result of that I lost my my title of
business development director whil
working at a umbrella company and had to
take a demotion back down to key account
manager now that was a big slap on my
ego and it was the first time that I had
to surrender to the fact well actually
maybe I truly am not good enough and
that was quite humbling in a way
difficult to take but
humbling um but my boss at the time said
some words to me that have stuck with me
forever and they were got to be honest
Dan you went away from the business on
lockdown one person you've had 8 months
out doing whatever you've been doing
whil on lockdown and now you've returned
someone completely different I don't
even recognize Dan anymore and it was
one of those moments I don't know if
you've ever had this where words just
kind of cut through all of the noise and
it was like a hammer shattering my
identity and it was at that point when I
knew okay I've got to really pull my
[__] together here and start making some
some proactive changes and then shortly
after that I got rested so it's almost
like the universe's way of saying that
something's changing here dude you know
yeah I don't know if anyone else
listening has had moments like that I I
definitely had my moment with that it is
it is I do find it so interesting
that you can often just have those
certain moments and experiences that do
stick with you forever but I completely
agree when those words just like really
resonate and they just land different M
so for
me I was really fortunate I'm fortunate
I have a really great close friendship
group we're all doing our own thing
don't all live near each other we've all
ended up on our own paths but early
20s like all I cared about was other
people's opinions going out just the
normal stuff but then there was two
friends that started to not come to
socials as much much didn't come around
when we said we were just going to smoke
weed and watch Jordi Shaw and like they
started to sort of Splinter
off and because I am a quite curious
person like that did make me think like
why why are they not coming around like
why are they I just found that
interesting so my moment with that was
it it was actually it was actually on a
on a shroom trip the first ever one that
I did
with my close
friends like super safe environment we
literally started the trip by watching
High School Musical like and it was just
the the intention was we're going into
this experience together to get
something out of
it and I always remember it where we
were sitting on the beach obviously
fascinated by the Stars cuz they just
look mad when um uh when you've taken uh
shrooms
and I sort of something just clicked and
I understood why they were saying no to
the things that we'd always done AKA
going out or these things and it was a
simple realization that they were making
a decision on the best investment that
you can make is in yourself mhm and I
never that would that is not a
perspective I would have so that like
struck deep to me and I was like oh
they're just choosing to spend time on
themselves rather than time doing what
we were doing mhm and then from that
moment I was like okay what does that
look like for me what can I start doing
I started to read books and I just
started to explore this idea of spending
time on myself and that that was that
was like a huge Catalyst for me and
those words really cut deep and just
having that I just I always remember it
just it just clicked for me I was like
oh okay and then I've just continued on
that that Journey just thinking about
you know exploring me and myself yeah
that's a great Insight that you Shar
that that was me so I understand when
you have those moments how they feel and
they can genuinely change they can
really change things yeah yeah I
resonate with that a lot and you you
kind of opened up a a memory pathway for
me there one thing that I noticed whilst
I was going through my growth journey of
starting to similar to you read books
and watch YouTube videos and and that
kind of thing is that I was doing it all
wrong for many years it's almost
like I don't know what I'd call it maybe
toxic productivity you know and you feel
like you have to be reading new books on
selfhelp and all this kind of stuff and
one thing that I did and I can now
recognize as a major mistake is just
read everything and then I'd get
frustrated with myself thinking well why
is nothing going into my head I'm just
reading lines and I'm not actually
absorbing anything it's cuz I just
didn't give a [__] about it I just
wasn't bothered about the stuff that I
was reading and I don't know if you
found something similar that the second
I proactively thought about what I
really want to learn about like what
actually interests me what excites me
what could I get really curious about
learning and personal development became
so much easier that words just naturally
fall into your mind and you absorb it
like a sponge because it's something
you're genuinely interested in and for
so many years having always been
relatively ambitious and and
growth-minded are just reading the wrong
thing or looking at the wrong thing or
pursuing the wrong path because I
thought that it was the right thing to
do as opposed to what actually excites
me what lights my soul up what do I want
to learn about no I can definitely I was
just like obsessed with thinking about
how I can be just become
better is is what I was super curious
about so I I definitely resonate with
that yeah so that pivotal moment of
you're someone that's different yes
obviously I know then you had the
experience in wh but was that important
then because you had someone almost
validate that you you had made changes
and you're someone that yeah was going
in a different direction or clearly like
you must have been feeling that you are
starting to like you said like trying to
process this emotion not push it away
not fall into old habits and you had
someone that had know like that known
you obviously had a perception of you
literally label you as someone that is
different and I'm assuming you took that
as in like different in a good way like
yes he's noticed that I am trying to go
in this direction I am trying to make
different decisions or I am trying to
become a better person well no actually
no kind of but in indirectly like I I
certainly didn't perceive it as positive
at the time and really yeah this this is
we're now getting into the
um the high function
element of the work that I do now
because my boss said that to
me because the person who he perceived
me to be before going on lockdown was
what he saw as being the better person
it was the productive Dan it was highly
driven it was you know getting work done
despite the fact that I was still going
out and I was partying doing all that
kind of stuff he didn't know about that
right he just he just saw the Dan who's
hitting his targets and pushing the
needle forward so he saw that identity
die and thought what's happened what's
gone wrong here meanwhile I'm thinking
to myself yeah I'm actually starting to
really get better and he's gone no you
are something's not right here does that
make sense yeah that makes sense it's
actually the opposite way around which
is why it was so impactful at the time
because I was like well I thought that I
was doing things right here and I've
just been told that whoever I am is not
right so that's why it was so impactful
but what that did in a roundabout way
was shatter that old identity and put
that to rest
and in that immediate moment was very
hard to take they were they were
impactful words but I then knew that
okay I've got a new identity that I
really need to step into and start
building here because the old one's gone
old down is is is is no more so um had
to leave Wales after the arrest and then
for whatever reason I felt an intuitive
nudge towards moving to Manchester so I
moved to Manchester at that point in
time that's where I still live to this
day now and um
it was two months after moving to
Manchester in December
2021 that I hit my absolute lowest so
that is where I hit what I would call
Rock Bottom for weeks and weeks and
weeks leading up to the 18th of December
which I'll explain the importance of in
a moment I felt like I was
Ill it didn't feel like an emotional
pain that I was experiencing I
was constantly going backwards and forth
the doctor to try and get a diagnosis on
what was actually going on inside of me
and they said you're fine there's
absolutely nothing wrong we've got no
sign of illness no sign of covid nothing
to suggest that there's anything wrong
with you meanwhile I can't get out of
bed in the mornings I'm I'm struggling
to motivate myself to work I'm feeling
pressure in my head and something is
clearly not quite right in my body and
it's interesting you mention um shrooms
a moment ago at at that time I was
experimenting with micro doing and I was
micro doing LSD and it wasn't the
regular type of LSD which is like paper
it was this weird like plastic stuff and
it was very very hard to measure out the
right micro do it's Wednesday morning I
measure out what I perceive to be a
micro dose and then at 8:36 in the
morning the words start jumping out my
computer screen I'm think oh no what
have I done and it certainly wasn't a
micro do and that day was when I came to
the realization that I am incredibly
depressed and it's not an illness that
I'm trying to diagnose it is just my
denial of the fact that I am in
emotional pain wow and it was the LSD
that helped me get to that moment of
realization so um same friend who passed
me that book speaking to him about it
telling him what was going on he said
I'm going to be honest dude it sounds
like you're depressed yeah I am you need
therapy so that's when I started going
to a real therapist as opposed to my
friend and um it was from that point
that my life completely changed because
all of those emotions that I was
packaging away they were now here right
you know I said before that I was kind
of trying to let them in they were all
there all at once hence why I was
experiencing that depression and Jim KY
who everybody listening to this will
will know has got a a great um a great
metaphor for depression and I make him
WR on this he
says depression is when a person goes
into a state of deep rest the role that
they've been playing is no longer
suitable anymore and they just need to
rest from that and recover and that's
what was going on for me that identity
that I was living through up until that
point was no more and the reintegration
of authentic honest Dan was then taking
place and that come with a lot of
processing of the adoption of their
grief of losing my mom at 18 of just
understanding what it meant to do a
complete identity shift and rebuild and
processing all the emotion that came
with that it all kind of hit me at once
so I'm started doing therapy with my
therapist H at the time and really
focused on actually becoming the best
therapist I possibly could so I stopped
um drinking on the 18th of December 2021
and I haven't drank since and I don't
really think I ever will again to be
honest I've I've achieved so much
between now and then that I've got no
reason to go back to it and it was all
as a result of experiencing and
understanding that I was in a depressive
State and I needed to make some pretty
serious changes in order to get out of
it and committing to no drink and drugs
and all the rest of it was was one of
the one of the factors towards that so
what what has how like what are like the
key things cuz then I I want to go into
how you now help people cuz but I'm
assuming a lot of things you know help
people is is also what you experience
for yourself
but what are like the important things
that having that time of a therapist
helped you do like why was that why did
that end up really helping you and
obviously it's a continuous Journey but
like when you had all that emotion to
process and like you said like you was
depressed and then you started to work
with your therapist like how did that
help you what is it that that that
therapy time gave you or enabled you to
do and why was it so important firstly
it gave me the understanding that
addiction is a symptom not the
problem we generally perceive whatever
the behavior is whether it's cocaine
alcohol gambling sex porn whatever
doesn't matter it's almost irrelevant to
to a degree the first thing going deep
into therapy myself did is helped me
understand that addiction is a symptom
of the underlying problem the underlying
problem in my case was the pain being
adopted it was the grief of mom it was
um the identity crisis and the the the
anxiety that I was experiencing so it
helped me get to the route and resolve
all of those core experiences that were
causing me to feel anxious and
depressed so that when they're gone
they're no longer a problem anymore
there's no reason for me to go and need
cocaine or alcohol does that make sense
how I've explained that as being a
symptom so you've got the addictive
behavior in my case let's say
cocaine is being fu fueled by anxiety
it's being fueled by
self-doubt
anxiety is an aggravation not an emotion
so the anxiety is being fueled by in my
case shame and guilt as a result of all
of my past decisions and grief from
losing my mom and they are core
wounds resolve the core wound all of the
other stuff Falls away because it has
nothing holding it together anymore so
that was the m your Insight
understanding that oh I don't just love
getting high this is for a reason I'm
doing this to avoid something yeah
so spending that time with a therapist
made you just go down look at like you
said like the core wounds and the the
deeper layer your subconscious whatever
yeah however you would describe it
but you hadn't up until that point
really peel back the layer on ultimately
like why you're doing the things you
were doing and why you're making
decisions you are making you just
thought I'm making these decisions
because
I'm addicted to Coke or like I enjoy
this but actually it made you really
look
at where yeah where this was being where
this was truly being driven from yeah
previously I was one of those people and
there will be many of them listening to
this podcast I've just got an addictive
personality yeah you hear that all the
time it's a get out jail free card isn't
it it's it's okay I've just got an
addicted
Personality yeah but why right it made
you think about the why yeah before you
hadn't no I just accepted it as part of
my identity and we'll do this we'll form
whenever we begin a statement with I or
I am or I am not that's an identity
statement so if you're saying I have an
addictive personality or I am an
addictive person that's the reality that
you're creating for yourself instead of
just accepting that as the way you are
ask yourself why where could that be
coming from what's the reason for it M
we're not confined by these beliefs that
we trap ourselves within if you don't
want to have an addictive personality
ask yourself where it could be coming
from and do something to change that so
if it helps you understand that it
really helps you go to like the core
wounds yeah if I now
know what my core wounds are I'm
assuming then what's like the next thing
that really helps you is it you then
spend time processing yes those core
wounds and trying to understand them or
is is that then what it helps you with
yeah that's right so the first step is
understanding what the core runes are
and then you want to find the right
therapist who can help you get there and
the number one predictor of success in
therapy is not the form of therapy it's
the relationship between the therapist
and the client as simple as that
interesting so there are some forms of
therapy that will work better for
others but finding the right person to
help you get there is the most important
thing and you can get there at alone
right there are some people who process
their wounds and their trauma without
going to therapy it's possible you
mentioned psychedelics psychedelics can
be a way of getting there it's certainly
not for everyone I'm not going to sit
here and recommend it but the important
takeaway within this point of the
conversation is you need to go to the
darkness in order to resolve it and
that's An Inconvenient Truth About
personal development and growth growth
is very uncomfortable because what
you're doing is going to places that
you've never been before and if you're
somebody who's struggling with addiction
and you have never even turned your
attention in was to face your mistakes
in the past your challenging situations
that you've experienced whether that be
um inside or outside of your family with
with trauma Etc if you're not willing to
go into that then you're not going to
resolve it you can do that on your own
or you can do that with a therapist is
entirely up to you but you have to go
into the darkness in order to see the
light so describe describe
these uh high functioning professional
timy what do they typically look like
their behaviors decisions what what do
these people typically look like what
identities do they hold it's me it's me
five years ago that's the whole reason I
created this business and and and
focused on the niche that I do now is
because I was on paper very successful I
had a good job I had a great car um in
the past I've I've had girlfriends
whilst having a good
job out of my own place earning good
money but I was struggling and I didn't
know who to turn to for that I was often
very anxious very stressed because I was
working in a high press environment
which is often driven by kpis there's
inherent pressure that comes as a result
of that and I didn't know who to turn to
so the people who I work with
now primarily work with me because they
can see that I have been in their shoes
before it's the polarity dual life on
paper very successful everything
suggests that life is moving in the
right direction but
inside often very
unfulfilled lacking true purpose and
feeling overwhelmed and anxious and
that's then causing them to go and take
drugs or drink or gamble or watch a load
of porn or whatever the addictive
behavior is it could be anything it's
the polarity of success and struggle
success on the outside and struggle on
the inside so when
does I wanted to ask you this with your
own
experiences when do we cross the line
of addiction if you get what I mean so
like when
does watching porn become I'm addicted
to porn mhm or like vice versa with
alcohol cuz I feel like you can always
like you said give yourself a get out of
jail free card when you say I've just
got a bit of an adictive personality or
I only do it on the weekends but like
yeah when I don't know I don't know if
there's like a a definition or a clear
like line everyone's different but what
when would you say we're sort of getting
into the territory with our habits and
our decisions that maybe you'd feel
like is yeah would like is it would you
agree that you maybe are
addicted to alcohol I don't know when do
we cross that
line I guess it might be helpful if I
just Define what addiction is yeah to me
anyway there's there's going to be
different definitions depending on who
you ask but to me addiction is any
behavior that we continue doing despite
the known negative
consequences the final part of that
statement is the most important right
the known negative consequences yeah and
the consequences are going to vary in
level of severity depending on what the
addiction is porn could be considered to
be quite low consequence if you're
watching it maybe one two times per week
if you're watching it three four times
per day every day that's pretty high
consequence alcohol can be moderated for
many people others abuse it to the point
where they could end up having liver
damage and
toxicity so the consequence is dependent
on the
individual but having the awareness of
what those consequences are and how
they're impacting one's life is really
the crucial Point here and how what do
they sound like cuz that's what I'm
interested in like what do those
consequences often found sound like from
these high functioning professionals is
it I feel ashamed or every time I do it
I don't like the person I am like what
do those what do those consequences
often sound like cuz I think that's
where that could be helpful for people
CU they might be having that internal
dialogue yeah yeah it depends on very on
person to person but shame is something
that comes up again and again and again
embarrassment is the word that most
people resonate with because shame isn't
a word that we want to go near really
but a lot of people feel embarrassed and
guilty about their past decisions but I
focus primarily on substances that's
what I work with most often that would
be alcohol primarily and cocaine they're
the two core um addictions that I work
with I have worked with others like
gambling and what we call Process
addictions like sex and porn and
gambling falls into that as well but
primar work with substances so for
people who are experiencing those
consequences if you're using cocaine and
alcohol what you'll probably be
experiencing and you may not even be
aware of it it's a lot of brain fog and
lack of clarity it's almost like a mask
that these substances put within our
mind and you don't know what it's like
to get out of that until you stop but a
lot of the clients who approach me to
work with me are experiencing a lot of
brain flog lack of clarity lack of
purpose in so far as feeling very
unfulfilled and they're often quite
anxious and that's like the um physical
symptoms of it but in terms of the
um social it often affects family
Dynamics particularly alcohol affects
family Dynamics because when you're
abbreviated you're um you're not there
you're not present and that can have an
inherent effect on the connection that
you have with your family as well and
then of course going into the
professional world if you're
experiencing a lack of clarity that's
going to have an inherent effect on your
work performance so your performance
isn't going to be as good as it possibly
could be and these are all often
unconscious we don't even know about
this stuff because it's just so systemic
and normal to go out and drink and take
Coke and all of the rest of it that we
just accept that it's the way it is but
there is a better way if I'm so if I'm
feeling those things I feel like it is
I'm just doing it maybe too often I do
want to change I'm finding it hard to
change I'm not not sure why I always end
up in a situation with my mate at 4:00
a.m. sniffing Coke like why do I always
end up here on a Friday Su Saturday
night like what what have you found to
be the common reason why I
don't reach for help or look
to speak to someone that could
potentially help me with that be therapy
like what what is it that even though I
could be feeling those things what often
holds people back from taking that first
step to maybe getting help that's a
great question fear of judgment really
yeah fear of judgment I've had
over I think at least five people
messaged me privately on LinkedIn saying
I absolutely love your content but I
can't engage with it because I'm afraid
that my employer will see it and judge
me really isn't that
telling yeah so fear of judgment is a
big one and then particularly for men
and I would have F fell into this
category back when I was 21 22 years old
therapy as a word is quite loaded it's
quite energetically charged when you
hear therapy generally most people's
mind will go to that's for broken people
yeah I I'd probably agree with that yeah
whereas you hear coaching and you're
like oh that's going to make me
better therapy has got a
certain stigma and notion that's
attached to it and less so with women
but more so with men a lot of men are
resistant to go to therapy because they
will feel weak if they do so so that's a
a big roadblock or barrier that I see in
people reaching out for help I think
that's changing over the over time you
know the mental mental health movement
is is doing good things for that but
there is still a lot of resistance for
for from a male perspective to reaching
out for
help it is really interesting on the on
the Judgment thing
M cuz that that must be tough
because if you're if you say oh I
actually started working with an
addiction
therapist that then means you're going
to have to start explaining to people
that you're you would maybe uh deem
yourself as an addict it's a double
whammy isn't it cuz not only are you
admitting that you have an addiction but
you're also going to therapy which yeah
and you might not be equipped to
really you know dissect that with people
or
like have the have the confidence to
talk like to say yeah I actually i' I'd
probably say yeah I
am an addict or I do really struggle
with this like that's that's tough I I
do get that and also as we we said when
you do hear that word addict that that
also makes you feel and like feel and
assume certain things mhm
right it isn't the types of people that
you work with like when I when you say
the word adct you don't think someone
that's doing really well
financially has progressed their career
these things you think the opposite of
that that's right so I understand why so
if I if I took the courage to take that
first
step reach out to
you you start working together mhm what
is it that you're I know everyone's
different but like just to paint a bit
of a picture here if if someone you know
does have the the courage to reach out
for help like what what are you going to
look to do and you know help me discover
in those early sessions like what is it
that you really focus on cuz I'm sure
there's certain things that you are
intentional about to hopefully help me
as quickly as possible yeah where do you
tend to go so I split my programs up
into three stages past present and
future and I believe that each one of
those plays a crucial role in helping
live a life beyond addiction past
because as we've spent a lot of time
speaking about today contributes to who
we are in the present so all of my past
struggles and pain and Trauma is what
was keeping me trapped in addiction so
the first thing we have to do when
helping someone get out of addiction is
build a solid foundation that comes by
way of resolving the past so that's the
first part of the work that we do the
second part second third is looking at
the present so that's lifestyle and
behavioral modification so introducing
boundaries fortifying communication so
that particularly for high functioning
people who are in in work environments
where there's booze playing a role quite
often you need to feel confident going
into those social situations and being
able to hold your own and not feel like
you're going to cave in so we look at
adapting that introducing structure
structure equals freedom when we have
more structure less ambiguity we're way
less likely to push the [__] it button
and go and have a drink or get a bag of
Coke in or whatever and then the final
stag is is future so this is where we
look at fulfillment and purpose and this
is not something that I see spoken about
ever in the addiction or recovery
Community if you go to a a conventional
therapist for addiction they might be
able to help you stop the behavior but
the chances are you'll probably fall
back into the hole and go back into the
habit if you don't have a compelling
reason to stay away from it so for me
the thing that's kept me out all this
time is my purpose as a therapist and my
drive to help as many high functioning
humans out of addiction as I possibly
can that is way more compelling than
putting my nose in a bag of cocaine
that's my purpose that's my mission like
you're building this podcast and you're
building your platform that's your
purpose you've got a a deep why as to
why you're doing it I presume mhm it
makes it a lot easier to say no you know
what I'm good I don't need that stuff
I've got some really really good stuff
going on over here I'm going to stay
going that way thank you so past present
future yeah I really like that I
understand the future
bit cuz you need you need though you
need that future bit in those moments
where you could cave in right it's
essential so I I totally get that that's
that's super
interesting so I'm I'm not going to be
able to discover those things if I don't
have the courage to reach out take that
first
step so cuz I'm sure you've helped
people with this or spoken to people
about it to get like practical for a
second what's ended up being your common
advice
about approaching the internal
perceptions that you're most worried
about you know particularly in the
recruitment setting do I want to be
known as the person in the office who's
an addict
probably not so
what how how would you encourage people
to navigate this like like you said
people worried about what their boss
would think these things I don't know is
there anything to share again everyone's
situation is different but is there
anything to share that could be a quite
sort of um tactful way of approaching
getting help when your biggest concern
is you don't want to be labeled as the
person that has an addiction problem cuz
then that comes with a whole weight of
other perceptions that how is he going
to keep his performance up MH like just
so many other things would go through my
head like other people's heads I feel
like in terms of like oh I now know this
person is you know would say they're an
addict and they're getting help like how
how do I navigate would I not should I
not tell anyone should I try and pick a
moment to speak to someone internally
about who I trust I don't know how how
have you helped people navigate that if
that's one of the biggest reasons why
people people uh don't ask don't get to
that point of asking for
help well the fear of judgment is a
really interesting conversation right
because the fear of judgment is usually
a narrative or a story that we create in
our own mind the story that we create is
often what's causing us to feel quite
uncomfortable about it and nothing's
actually happened yet we're usually time
traveling we're going out into the
future think oh what if this happens
what if they think that what if this
this happens usually nothing's actually
happened it's just the story that we're
creating in our head so um it needs to
be approached on a caseby Case basis but
any decent therapist will keep 100%
confidentiality I guarantee this to
every single person that I work with
unless um I ask for permission to share
a testimonial or something along those
lines I will not share anything and
that's because I understand that
the corporate work culture hasn't quite
caught up to where I'm at yet with
regards to openness and being vulnerable
on social media platforms and I'm not
expecting everyone to do that m it's got
to be approached with sensitivity on a
case-by casee basis if you feel that
you're under a lot of pressure in your
work environment right now and you need
space to work on yourself then that is a
moment where I would advise
communicating it to your employer and if
there's somebody who you trust within
that business who you can communicate it
to first in the confidence that they
won't say it to anybody else then that's
the way which I probably approach that
and you know most people have most
businesses sorry have a mental health
first aid representative within the
business these days that would be a
first Port of Call good person to start
with that would be a good person to
start with yeah and then beyond that if
you could go to a a senior member of
Staff providing you've got the
relationship to do that then that might
be a good move as well but there's
nothing saying that you have to if you
feel that that's going to cause you a
lot of anxiety and stress and discomfort
because of the fear that it might get
around everyone you don't need to keep
it to yourself you don't need to yeah
but there are tools to help offload
stuff that you feel is taking up
bandwidth in your mind if you feel like
you need to tell someone or just get
something out of your own conscious mind
and on onto paper then that's what I
recommend you do just grab a pen and
paper and just get your thoughts out of
your head and and do what I call a brain
dump get it out of your mind and
sometimes that can be quite relieving in
itself how helpful is it to
how helpful is it to label yourself an
addict not helpful at
all yeah it's hard it is hard it is hard
but it comes back to the point of
identity
again there's a big difference between
saying I am an addict to I experience
addiction okay same with anxiety
powerful right I I I am anxious I am an
anxious person or I experience anxiety
one yeah that's totally different
completely different one is very much
part of our experience and one is I'm
just experiencing emotion like any other
human
being yeah that's even that just slight
shift I feel like would entirely change
how I would perceive someone saying to
me yeah I'm like yeah like you would
feel entirely different if someone came
to you in your team to
say I wanted to be honest with you I'm
really struggling with this I think I'm
an addict yeah I think I'm addicted to
Coke whatever or I'm really struggling
with this I feel like I'm experiencing
addiction with yes that's that makes me
feel totally different yeah it's a big
shift it's a big shift and that's
something I
encourage um and what's the other reason
behind that because I feel like then
when you change it from an I am to I'm
experiencing the I am is like this is
what I am and it's sort of almost
saying you're sort of saying like this
is who you
are how's that work in my head I am
you're basically saying that that's who
I am
that's and then I'm experiencing is
basically say I feel like it's sort of
when you say I am it's like finite it's
like yeah this is who I am mhm there's
no changing
defines whereas
experiencing it's almost sort of makes
you feel like it's a moment yeah it's
like a period yeah not like yeah like
defined that's right yeah we are not
defined by our emotions or behaviors
yeah we are not our emotions that's just
energy moving through Us in the same way
that addiction is this creation that
we've put together as human beings it's
not something that
defines our Identity or our inherent
sense of self it's just something that
we do and the more that we can get away
from it and get distance away from the
behavior so that we can kind of look at
it objectively and understand it rather
than feeling so wrapped up in it like a
lot of the um addiction Community does
and I'm not going to sit here and talk
[__] about you know AA and people like
that they've helped millions of people
around the world I think that's great
and I think that there's no universal
truth as to who's going to help the most
people with addiction but you
know in the um in some of these uh
support groups and you have to go hi my
name's down and I am a alcohol addict or
whatever it's kind of promoting it right
it's kind of keeping people trapped up
it doesn't go against yeah your
philosophy I guess yeah and I'm not
sitting here saying that I am right you
know no you're just talking from your
own perspective and what out people is
right that's just part that's just yeah
yeah that's right but that that that is
that is a true point but I'm assuming I
haven't looked enough into it but I'm
assuming there's a real reason behind
that in terms of like
accepting
acceptance I coming to terms with who
you are what you're doing yeah but I do
but I think why you probably feel I'm
assuming here but why you probably feel
that way is cuz the the types of people
that you're working with it is a very
specific type of people
mhm yeah where we like we're saying if
I'm a high achieving professional
mhm to say to your boss that I am an
addict that probably isn't that probably
isn't that helpful no helpful way of
like communicating it I think that I am
experiencing these these feelings I'm
experiencing addiction with this I feel
like that would help a lot more people
in in those circumstances yeah
absolutely and it's the frame through
which we approach conversations like
that it may not it may not always be
necessary as we've said but in those
moments where you do need to have a
conversation because perhaps you need
some some time time out to frame it as
hey I am experiencing
some difficulty at the moment maybe I'm
feeling anxious I'm feeling a little bit
overwhelmed and I don't want you to feel
that my job performance is dipping for
any reason other than the difficulties
I'm experiencing with addiction I need
some time out to go and work on this
stuff any decent employer would be okay
with that and if they're not then I'd
encourage you to find a new
job
so to wrap this up then two things one
if I am someone that
maybe is experiencing addiction with
insert the
blank
firstly what do you want to leave me
with if I'm listening and that's that's
like someone that you're speaking to I
might not have the courage just yet to
reach out and and want help but I'm
maybe yeah feeling that the negative
consequences is something I want to stop
feeling mhm what like how what would you
sort of leave me with in terms of just
advice if but maybe I'm just you know
maybe one step away from asking for help
like what what would be helpful for me
to to hear from you two
things
one Ponder this
question if you shifted insert addiction
here what would change for
you if you stopped what would
happen reflect on that and if you can
grab a pen and paper and explore that
with words then that would be really
powerful because addiction is a an
automatic process we get caught in the
loop and we struggle to see beyond it in
order to give
yourself hope you need to start looking
beyond what you're currently
experiencing so if you were no longer
trapped by addiction what would be going
on in your life think about your
environment your behavior the people
around you how you'd be feeling what
values would become important to you
your beliefs explore
it and then something which was really
powerful for me was breath
work and the reason for that is because
I spent a lot of time in my head i'
overthink and be very worried about what
other people were thinking of me breath
work forces you to get into your body
and the more you can get into your body
the more chance you've got of
understanding your emotions the more
chance you've got of overcoming
addiction because as we now know that's
what they're driven by so for somebody
who's struggling they don't know what to
do they might not be ready to reach out
yet firstly ask yourself what life would
be like without addiction explore that
get clear on what that reality would
look like secondly get out of your head
and into your body and you can use tools
like breath b or you could do meditation
if you wanted to but just try and get
out of your head and into your body it's
awesome and then if I ready to reach out
how how can people work with you what
does that look like um ultimately by
following the application form that I've
got my website which be www. the
freedoms solution.com
apply or you can follow the link which
is on the um I don't know what it's
called on LinkedIn a button just just
below my name on LinkedIn you can check
me out there um or if you're not quite
ready to apply yet and you just want to
find a little bit more about me
specifically how I work and how we could
work together just shoot me a message my
DMs are always open I'm happy to have
conversations with people that way as
well awesome Dan it's been an absolute
absolute pleasure thank you for being
open honest uh vulnerable with
us and also just yeah just a big kudos
to you in you know turning this journey
and experience you've been on to the
reason why you want to help so many
other people I I always respect people
that go on that journey I think it's
amazing So yeah thank you so much for
joining me on the Pod thank you brother
it's been great